مره اخرى تعود المحطه النوويه في زابروجيا
مسرحا لالقاء الاتهامات بين موسكو وكيف
الجانب الاوكراني اتهم لجانب الروسي بزرع
ما قال انها مواد تشبه المتفجرات على اسطح
وحدات للطاقه
بدورها موسكو حذرت من عمل تخريبي اوكراني
قد يستهدف المحطه لا بل ان الشركه الروسيه
للطاقه النوويه حددت موعدا كانت الخامس من
الشهر الجاري لما قالت انه هجوم اوكراني
على المحطه النوويه بالمدفعيه والمسيرات
وسط سيل الاتهامات بين الجانبين ياتي نفي
اولي من الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بعدم وجود اي متفجرات حتى الان
خبراء الوكاله فتشوا اجزاء من محطه
لكنهم بحاجه لمعينه كافه المنشات لتاكيد
نهائي لما وصلوا اليه استنادا لتصريح
مديرها العام
بعيدا عن مخاطر الاستهداف المتعمد تعمل
المحطه التي سيطرت عليها روسيا مع بدايه
حربها وسط تحديات متكرره يتعلق اكثرها
بتجهيزات عمل المحطه نفسها
قبل ايام تم توصيل خط الكهرباء الاحتياطي
بعد توقفه لاربعه اشهر كانت المحطه خلالها
تغذى من خط خارجي واحد لتبريد المفاعل
وغيره مما يطلق عليها مستلزمات الامان
النووي
واجهت المحطه سبعه قطاعات لمصادر الطاقه
الخارجيه منذ بدء الحرب وفق المدير العام
لوكاله الطاقه الذريه ايضا انخفاض منسوب
مياه البحيره الناتج عن تفجير سدك خوفكا
الشهر الماضي ميدان مواجهه والاتهام ينطوي
على مغامره كبيره تتعدى حدود الجغرافي
الاوكرانيه فروسيه تسيطر على المحطه لكن
قواتها تواجه في الوقت نفسه هجوما
اوكرانيا مكثفا في جبهه مقاطعه زابروجيا
اما اوكرانيا التي بريت المحطه على ارضها
فتنتج لها خمس حاجتها من الكهرباء لكنها
في الوقت نفسه قد ينظر اليها كورقه ضغط
دولي العاصمه ضد روسيا لا شك ان هذه
المحطه النوويه الاكبر في اوروبا والعاشره
على مستوى العالم تبدو الان كقنبله موقوته
فاي تسرب نشعاعي فان تاثيره سيصل الى مئات
الكيلومترات في اوروبا وروسيا ما يعني
انتفاء امكانيه الحياه في نطاق الانتشار
ربما لعقود طويله مع ما يرافق ذلك من
امراض مميته مثل السرطان وتشوهات المواليد
كما حدث في مفاعل تشيرنوبل باوكرانيا في 8
نيات القرن الماضي